report can you please first clearly
state the relevant page number
and relevant paragraph number
so there we are um you'll let me know
when we're on uh
live streaming sonia
[Music]
yes chairman thank you sonya
good evening members and officers
welcome to
rockford district council's remote
meeting of the executive
and welcome in particular to anyone
watching this via
our youtube live stream can i just
remind members that we have an agenda
tonight
but there is also the supplementary
agenda that was also
issued which carries an item nine so
uh um we will go through the uh the
agenda but include item nine
right moving on to uh agenda item
one if i can take any apologies for
absence but looking around the screen
i think we're all here so uh we haven't
got any apologies for absence
agenda item two non-members attending
sonia can you uh read out the names of
any non-members attending please
yes chairman we've got councillor
danielle belton
councillor mike wolfkinson councillor
dave sparing
and councillor julie gooding
thank you sonya moving on to agenda item
number three chairman sorry um council
sparring's hand up i don't know if he
wants to speak or if he's just left out
from
council sparring you are speaking but
you are mute
sorry chairman i can't get
thank you thank you
thank you councillor right moving on to
agenda item three
um we have the minutes of the meeting
held on
the 4th of november are those minutes
agreed members agreed
great great thank you very much
those members are those minutes are
agreed
um item four are there any decorations
of
interest members
i can't see any hands being raised
right we move to item five um
and we have two questions on notice
um but i'm actually suggesting that we
take those between items seven
and eight when we're completing item
seven uh for
continuity and smoothness of the meeting
as they relate to item eight
it seems to make sense to me if members
agree is that uh
agreed as a sensible way forward great
agreed
thank you very much indeed um
right moving to uh agenda item
six that has referred to the executive
reports from other committees
that there are none members which takes
us neatly on to
item 7 which is discover 2020
200 years of hms beagle
and um the acting managing director
angela hutchings will now introduce that
report
over to you angela
thank you chairman members as you know
our planned event for
may of this year could not go ahead due
to the pandemic
i undertook to review the position to
see if we could reprise the event in
2021
reluctantly i've come to the conclusion
that it cannot be reprised in the form
that we'd intended it to be
but we can reprise some elements of it
delivered albeit in a limited form and
and preferably in conjunction with
another event
notwithstanding the advent of a covid19
vaccine
the logistics of organizing a public
event which is primarily an indoor
exhibition
in a way which will meet public health
requirements which are expected to be
with us
for some time in some shape or form are
not insignificant
nonetheless for the relatively modest
sum of the remaining budget
something commemorative could be
achieved and the recommendation
is therefore for you to approve me
working alongside the portfolio holder
with responsibility for tourism
to design and deliver something suitable
in the next municipal year
thank you members thank you angela um
right are there any uh questions of the
packing managing director
i can't see any hands so in that case
i will move on to the noting item which
says
to note the plans for the recreation
of the council-led beagle event project
and to agree that the portfolio holder
with responsible for tourism works with
the acting managing director to achieve
a suitable commemoration
for 2021 is that item noted members
thank you very much indeed
right moving on to agendum agenda item
eight um and uh as i said
earlier in the meeting um we will uh
move on to two questions two questions
that we've
received from councillor wilkinson
um council wilkinson would you be kind
enough to read out your first question
please
thank you chairman a decision has been
taken to be ratified
this evening by the executive to close
the mill hall and art center on a
permanent basis
on behalf of the residents who use this
facility what if any
consultation took place with those user
groups to investigate the impact on them
in addition why is this decision being
taken now
during a period of national lockdown
when attendance figures will be skewed
due to the kovic pandemic
would it not be better to wait until
life returned to some degree of
normality
please can financial figures be provided
to show the basis behind this decision
this decision has caused a great deal of
alarm and so an explanation is therefore
needed
thank you jim thank you councillor
wilkinson um
now the question was actually originally
addressed to me
um but in view of the fact that the
report tonight
is a report
from the portfolio holder for community
uh i will ask councillor mike webb
uh to answer this question relating to
leisure provision please
councillor webb thank you councillor
wilton and thank you
councillor wilkinson for the question
i've considered the question and
consulted with officers
and my response is as follows
fusion lifestyle have engaged with user
groups and organizations who had
bookings at the mill arts and event
center
prior to copied 19 regarding returning
to the censor
a number of the groups and organizations
that were able to return under the
government restrictions in place
indicated that they wouldn't be
returning at this time
and in some cases indicated that they
wouldn't be returning until everything
was back
to normal paragraph 6.4 of the report
refers to the evidenced
lack of demand for the facilities
the council is satisfied that fusion
were proactive in looking to secure
bookings in the lead up to the reopening
but even before the pandemic the sites
ran at a significant loss
and therefore the cost to operate the
sites in the current climate
is unsustainable two different
variations of the contract have been
modelled over each two or three year
extension period
as outlined in paragraph 5.6 of the
report
both options allow cleveland's hall and
rayleigh leisure centre to remain
open option one which assumed the mill
arts and event center and castle hall
sites reopen until the redevelopment of
the mill arts and events centre
in june 2023 an option two which assumed
that the meal arts and event center and
castle hall
sites are mothballed both options assume
that the freight house site remains
mothballed
as agreed by the executive in august
2022
the estimated cost of both options for
both a two year and a three year
extension period is set out in table two
of paragraph 5.6 there would be an
additional pressure on the medium-term
financial strategy
of approximately 180 000
pounds if the mill art and event center
and castle hall were
reopened this is over double the
pressure on the median term financial
strategy
compared to the current budget and the
preferred option of mothballing the two
sites as a council we need to show value
for public money
and due to the low uptake of the mill we
would be heavily subsidizing any use
and this is not sustainable the sites
were running a loss pre-covered and
kovit has only exacerbated this issue
thank you thank you councillor webb
um can i just go back to a point that
you made just for clarity
um you referred to a decision as made by
the executive
just for clarity that was in august 2020
just a month or two a few months
months ago that's correct yes now
councillor wilkinson you were um uh very
good in putting
two or three questions within one
question so uh i think you've agreed
that there won't be any supplementaries
to
uh to that question and thank you for
that agreement um
but uh you also submitted a second
question
uh and uh if i could ask you please to
read out your second question
again that's got a multitude of
individual questions in it but uh
very happy if you'd like to go through
that please comment it is chairman yes
thank you i have it i have pushed the
limits somewhat
thank you councillor webb for your um
your response in relation to my first
question
chairman uh item eight uh just this
evening also discusses extension by
three years
the current contract with fusion
lifestyle post march 2021
my question is have other companies been
explored to see if we could achieve
better service and better value for
money for the taxpayers
if not then why has no tender process
taken place and why has no other company
been considered for this contract
and i say this i'm aware of the uh under
the regulation test to
subsection two c of the public contract
regulations 2015 authorities
are permitted to do this in cases of
quote extreme emergency
sorry a bigger pardon scream urgency
seeing as we've known this contract was
upcoming for some time how can this
council claim this is a case of extra
emergency
thank you councillor wilkinson and again
i'm going to go to councillor webb
to provide an answer to that question
please counselor
thank you councillor wilson and again
thank you councillor wilkinson
for the question um the answers i'll
give you are taken from the report and i
will be referring to that
throughout my response as stated in
paragraph 2.2 of the report as
agreed at the meeting of the executive
in august 2020
and in consultation with myself the
portfolio holder for community and the
portfolio holder for finance
and the assistant director assets and
community
initiated negotiations with fusion to
agree a new commercial arrangement for
the operation of the council's leisure
sites
beyond the 2020-21 financial year
paragraph 2.3 of the report states that
as reported to the executive in august
2020
it was proposed to modify the existing
contract terms
further to include the period from april
22
to a new end date which would enable the
council to be clear about its proposed
next steps for future service provision
paragraph 3.4 of the report states that
the council had planned to tender for a
new leisure contract to commence
on the 1st of april 2022 in accordance
with its leisure
leisure and cultural services strategy
officers have been working with a sport
leisure and cultural consultancy
to prepare a procurement exercise which
was due to commence in january 2021
this was considered the latest state a
procurement exercise could begin
in order to run a competitive procedure
prior to the current contract
ending paragraph 3.5 of the report
states that the kovid 19
forced the council to reconsider its
approach since procuring a new contract
in a commercially uncertain environment
would be unlikely to achieve
value for money or incentivize
innovation or investment
by a service provider paragraph 7 of the
report details the alternative options
considered
including other operators specifically
paragraph 7.4 to 7.6
refer to the option of another operator
taking over the operation of the
council's leisure sites
and the advantages that the incumbent
has
paragraphs 1.4.10 to 1.4.12
of the briefing note from the sport
leisure and cultural consultancies state
that the alternative to agreeing a
contract with fusion
extension with fusion lifestyle would be
to resume the process of procuring a new
contract from april 2022
the time scales to do this will be
challenging but achievable but with a
number of associated risks
the operator market is in an in an
uncertain position
with some operators not currently
exploring new contract opportunities
and all are understandably adopting a
more risk-averse position
seeking to share more of the major risk
areas with local authorities
and to protect themselves against
similar future closures and restrictions
it is possible that an initial period of
open book would be required to provide
more more comfort to bidders in the
first year the overall financial
position will be less favorable than it
would have been pre-covered
or could be in the future when operators
have more certainty over the leisure
market
and recovery of demand for facilities
and services
this alternative would also require the
negotiation of terms for the final year
of the contract with fusion
which would need to be on a similar open
book basis as the current financial year
it is also possible that without the
incentive of a contract extension
fusion would insist on a margin in their
cost for this final year
the council would have very little
leverage in negotiating the position for
this financial year
and the cost would likely be higher than
those inclu included for 20 21 22
within the financial submission for the
contract extension thank you
thank you councillor webb thank you
councillor wilkinson for those two
questions uh thank you very much
right we now turn to uh item eight
which is the leisure service provision
um from
april 2021 and uh
councillor webb um we're putting a lot
of pressure on you tonight but
if you would be kind enough please to
introduce the report
thank you councillorton i would like to
actually start
my presentation this evening with a
quote from the bbc news website that i
read this morning if that's okay
and this quote said more than 200
swimming pools in england will remain
closed
despite being able to reopen as lockdown
restrictions are eased
a swim england report has said
the swimming body said that the decision
presented a catastrophe
for the health and well-being of the
nation
the 221 pools were council run
affecting about half a million swimmers
i'm pleased to say that we are not one
of these 221
local authorities our swimming pool
essential for not only adults physical
health and wellbeing
but for that of our school children who
are still learning to swim
will remain open in addition to our
leisure center in rochford being
remaining open our leisure center in
raleigh will also remain open
for use by the public indeed the
swimming pool in rochester today was
nearly fully booked
fusion leisure and their staff who are
mainly local residents
have responded positively to the crisis
working extremely hard to make the
venues coveted secure
and also working extremely hard on
improving communications
i've personally visited both sites as i
know have many other members
and i was extremely impressed
watchful district council continue to
monitor the contract with fusion and the
services that they provide
ensuring that they don't become
complacent
our leisure facilities are an essential
part of our community
and i'm pleased that both sites will
remain open indeed they have both
reopened today
and in order to support this i'm pleased
to announce that fusion have just
confirmed
that all members of the two leisure
sites will be sent a free
three-day referral pass to be given to
friends or family
as we know kobe 19 has created a
significant economic impact within the
leisure sector
and is projected to have a longer
national impact on the industry as well
both due to the restrictions operators
have to operate under
and because of the reduction in demand
from site users confidence in returning
to use them
as already stated in my earlier response
because of this
there will be an additional pressure on
the median time financial strategy
of approximately 180 000 pounds
if the meal arts and events center and
castle hall were to be reopened
this is over double the pressure on the
median term financial strategy
compared to the current budget and their
preferred option of mothballing the two
sites
as a council we need to show value for
public money due to the low uptake of
the mill
we will be heavily subsidizing any use
and this is not sustainable
the sites we're running are lost
pre-covered and kovid has only
exacerbated this issue
fusion lifestyle has engaged with users
groups and organizations who had booking
at the mill arts and event center prior
to
covid regarding returning to the center
and although a number of these groups
and organizations that were able to
return onto the government restrictions
in place indicated that they wouldn't be
returning at this time
and in some cases indicated that they
wouldn't be returning until everything
was back
to normal
the council is satisfied that fusion
were proactive in looking to secure
bookings in the lead-up
to reopening but even before the
pandemic the sites found
a significant loss and therefore the
cost to operate the sites in the current
climate
is unsustainable however
i am pleased to say that this will not
be the end of the story
although i have seen various comments
stating that the mood is closing as a
result of the asset programme
this is not the clay is not the case
the middle is closing earlier than
anticipated due to the covert pandemic
for the reason set out above
but a new purpose-built community
facility
will be built on the site under the
asset program
we have asked our partners gb
partnerships to explore bringing forward
this aspect of the aztec programme and
to build a modern
fully equipped fit for purpose
sustainable community center
as soon as possible and certainly by the
summer of 2023
we are fortunate that the council has
been forward thinking and has already
got a plan in place
that we can now bring forward in
addition i'm pleased to announce that we
will be launching our new website
outlining the new facilities
tomorrow
so to conclude while the council does
regret not being able to open
to sustain the mill it is positive that
we are able to secure both the future of
clements hall leisure center
and rady leisure centre for the use of
our residents thank you
council webb thank you very much indeed
for that and
uh if i may before i open it up to
questions um because of the importance
and the seriousness with which we look
at the report tonight
i asked for a meeting with the chief
executive of
fusion mr peter k i received the letter
today
and i think it's worthy of me reading
out a few paragraphs
in that letter it says rochford district
council will benefit from a capped
financial position in 2021 to 2022
while the income share arrangements
which is the first of this sort that
fusion has ever entered into
offers significant upside potential and
an immediate opportunity for the council
to benefit from any over-performance
against the revenue targets i think that
is a superb piece of negotiation on the
part
of our assistant director matt harwood
white
because it gives confidence to what
we're actually looking at tonight
he goes on to say we are also willing if
good quarter 4
20 20 to 21 january to march
shows a positive performance to discuss
with the council of possible reprofiling
and revised cost proposition ready for
april 2021
we continue to be fully committed to
rockford and we will use our best
commercial endeavors to drive down the
cost
and improve the revenue to deliver on
the contract extension
and to share any success with the
council
our financial position gives us a stable
and sustainable future
and enables us to invest in both the
facilities
and additional personnel in rockford to
deliver
the exciting active communities agenda
and i read those paragraphs to you
because they are the paragraphs that
gave me confidence to reflect on the
wider aspects of this report
because i think between our assistant
director
matt hold white and members of
fusion they have really gone to
uh extreme lengths to ensure that
rochford is
in a strong position with fusion as our
leisure provider partner
so with that i will now open it up to
remember questions but can i just remind
members that there are two exempt
appendices to the report
if you need to make reference to either
of these appendices
can you please indicate before speaking
as it will be necessary to move a
recommendation to exclude the present
public first
are there any questions from members of
the executive please and i see a number
of hands
and i'm going to go straight to
councillor rowe
cheryl rowe thank you chairman
we must not lose sight of the fact that
we have two separate issues in respect
to the closure of the mill hall
as has already been said number one it
is part of the asset delivery programme
number two covid and our repeat covid
has forced us
into an earlier decision to probably
close the hall earlier and i get that
the real shame is the mistruths being
put out out there on facebook
some by councillors who should know
better to be honest
most of the residents that i have spoken
to start off very unhappy
and when you explain what is really
happening i think they wonder why they
believe the nonsense on social media at
times
that said i have several questions for
the officers please
number one will users that have already
booked the mill hall get a full refund
number two how many groups use the mill
hall
currently number three
how many bookings diffusion have either
groups or individuals
number four how am i to be convinced
that fusion won't keep coming back for
more financial help
number five how soon can we bring the
development of the new build forward
so that we are not left without
community space
six will officers and or fusion
help users of the mill hall relocate
raley is a town that i have grown up in
and love
sometimes there has to be changes and
hopefully in the next day or so when the
new voyage website
is launched detail in our new journey
residents will hopefully all realize
that the right decisions
have been made going forward thank you
chairman
helpful thank you very much indeed and i
should have also said that
much to councillor webb's pleasure i
believe uh matt harwood white will be
assisting in answering some of the
questions
if he was fast enough to scribble down
some of those questions for the uh
to give answers so uh i suspect you want
to go over to
uh matt holwood why something i think
thank you chairman dvd members um yes i
did i think i've got most of those
council rowe um forgive me i've missed a
couple if i have done
it i'll come back to them um in terms of
the first one
um that was user's refund yes happy to
confirm that fusion
will offer for refunds they did um for
the freight house and they will they
will similarly honor that for
uh the mill um we'll just need details
of those groups
um contacted by a fusion and we can make
that happen or if you'll make that
happen
um in terms of bookings we do have that
information in terms of numbers of
bookings
um it's part of what we've done i don't
have it to hand but i can make that
available if that's helpful
um i believe nine groups
per week we use thank you councilwoman
thank you thank you councilwood
um in terms of
um the suburbs around financial
impact was it councillor third one how
many bookers diffusion have either as
groups and individual bookings that was
nine was it and how many groups used the
meal hall currently
so how many groups actually have had
bookings prior to covid
we have that information as part of the
analysis i know i sent that to you
separately in writing that's okay cancer
right
i don't have that to hand oh that's fine
thank you you asked in terms of um
working with groups to relocate them
yes there's a there's a note in the
report and there's a commitment from the
council's
uh leisure and cultural services team to
work with any groups
to help them find alternative um
accommodation whilst we're developing
the sites through the asset program so
yes
definite commitment from us to help work
with groups to do that can i just come
back there
matt please so people like ready
horticultural who
have events just three times a year
obviously they need a big haul
other than schools
which are quite expensive i believe
there isn't really anywhere that can
accommodate that
and that is something that really goes
down well in in raleigh
so i think we need to to really help
them find somewhere
suitable if you could make a note of
that map clothes and contacts
i can give you the contact details of
the person's contact thank you that'd be
helpful thank you
i've noted that as well um
in terms of bringing the site forward um
um
through the asset program yes um as
scanter web sets out we
we have um spoken to our partners gv
partnerships
and following any decision this evening
they will be working with us to
investigate how we can bring
the site forward in the asset programme
to um to achieve an earlier date to
complete the new purpose-built
sustainable facility at that site
so yes that we will work to do that man
come back chairman please
certainly thank you so can we make sure
that's a priority
matt in that we find that information
out as soon as possible i'd like
to have some kind of indication just
that so that us as councillors can keep
our residents in
in the loop um in respect of the
how can i be convinced that fusion won't
keep coming back for more financial help
i don't think we've answered that one
so um the report's written
um and the contract is a um a capped
position
in in year one so an open book process
capped in year one
um and then in the following years again
it's a it's a fixed payment
so that'll be um written into the
contract we have refusing going forward
um under that under the contract
extension
okay matt come back chairman please
certainly just very quickly thank you
so we're not likely to see um
or hear of fast uh increases in
in financial help as we had in the
summer
there's no um
there's no contr as as in the summer
there's there would be if there was a um
further lockdown that that could
potentially to another
negotiation outside of the contract but
this is based on
um the projections they have for a
recovering market
anything outside of that would be a um a
separate contraction arrangement we
would have to debate
um outside of this contract um this
contract doesn't allow for that that'll
be a separate conversation
with the same arguments in the summer in
terms of contract frustration and
thank you matt thanks for your help
thank you chairman
thank you councillor um and can i just
um
there is sometimes reference to a uh
building a community space or a
community facility
and can i just sort of make it
absolutely clear
we are talking about a brand new
significantly um dedicated standalone
bespoke purpose-built community building
with flexible space which is cost
effective to operate
and that is what we're talking about
this is a
new building equipped to
up-to-date standards which runs
and is a multi-purpose facility which
should be attractive
attractive to a number of user groups
and i just wanted to insert that point
there
uh counsellor after you have your hand
up
thank you chairman um i'll just read a
little bit on the language
where the officers keep saying this is
people kids preferred option
i don't see this as a preferred option i
don't think any of us really
prefer shutting
community centers and stuff like that i
think this is the most sustainable
option
going forward and
i like to hear that hopefully we can
bring
forward with gb partnerships the
new mule hall which will be
carbon uh excellent as well as all the
other things you said there
chairman and i just don't want it to be
confused that we prefer to do this we
don't prefer to do this this is the most
sustainable
thank you council fd i think that's an
excellent point um whilst
uh it may run into semantics about the
word
i think it is well worth emphasizing the
fact
there is no implication that we prefer
this because we favor it
it is a question of considering uh the
reality
of costs and i think you make a really
good point um it is an option
but it is not there should be absolutely
no doubt
it's preferred by virtue of the fact
that we favor it
uh and i thank you for making that uh
that point
uh and you've also made a point that was
referred to in councillor webb
and i think councillor alluded to it as
well about the possibility and
and ideally we would have hoped not to
be in this place
but certainly and and i now put my hat
on
um looking at the asset program and i'm
trying not to muddy the waters too much
tonight
but certainly the um opportunity
if that's the right word too to look at
the middle hall site to see whether
there is any way that we can
accelerate to the program i do want to
emphasize the fact that
we're talking about in any case the new
community building opening in the summer
of 2023
that is just two and a half years away
which sounds in some respects a long
while
but when you think we've got to go
through planning and the various aspects
i think it's a pretty stretching target
um to actually plan and build a uh
an exciting new facility at the time
we're talking about
but um mr harwood white is in absolutely
no doubt
of my uh enthusiasm for him to
work with gb partnerships to see whether
given the unfortunate circumstances that
we're in we can do
everything we can to accelerate the
program so that we can get that new
facility up and running because i think
one thing we can be
very sure of in the light of the news
today on vaccines
the rollout of next week that in two and
a half years time
hopefully this should all be history and
we should be in a much happier place
thank you councillor fd all right i'll
move to councillor ian
ward council award thank you chairman
um councillor actually brought up
something
um where she mentioned uh the reigning
multicultural society
and because i'm a member i therefore
need to declare an interest
as a member i i never declared it before
because i didn't realize it
in into the conversation as regard
to uh being one of the the people who
have lobbied in regards they've lobbied
me as well
as i'm sure they have lobbied many of
the rayleigh councillors
as well as i've been lobbied quite
seriously by a lot of residents
in regards to the closure of the real
world
but from the report and from what we've
heard and what we're discussing
i i'm very very pleased to actually have
some clarity
in regards and this clarity gradually
coming into the public domain
because the biggest problem and i think
councillor did echo
this very very point that
members of the public have been coming
up to me saying
phone reports from various areas
that the mill hall was going being
replaced by housing
and that was it nothing else there was
nothing else going to happen it was just
that was it end story and i've had to
explain to them that
actually that is not the case i'm
looking forward
to seeing um this uh
how can i put it can someone guide me
onto what this thing is called
that's coming out um
[Music]
someone guide me on it i've completely
forgotten the name because i haven't
avoided the voyage
i i have not said i'm i am just as
interested as everybody else
to actually see what it's about and what
it contains
um but i think the most important factor
is there's going to be replacement there
is going to be
a state of the art and i know that the
people who have been working
on the working group of which i'm not a
member but
they have assured me that they have
fought extremely hard
and they have knocked back against some
of the suggestions
i've been told that came forward and
said i'm sorry
these are not good enough these are not
good enough
for rayleigh and they need to be
improved and i know they've played
hardball serious hardball to ensure that
rayleigh
will end up with a superb facility
thank you very much jim thank you
councillor
ward and certainly um at the point i
became
a portfolio holder uh i took a keen
interest
to ensure that uh our provision uh
at that location uh was top quality
and even though
provision of these services is
discretionary for the council
i took a strong line and said rainey
deserves better it is going to get
a quality replacement it deserves it
and it's getting it and that will happen
councillor simon smith thank you
chairman
um i don't think we should underestimate
the challenge which
councillor webb and mr harwood white
have been through in this
current situation which of course is
still ongoing and vaccine or not will
continue to have an impact well into
next year
i listened in detail to what counselor
webb
said and i would like to commend him for
his speech it was full
of detail and reflected what i know
has been the many hours and hours of
detailed conversation and negotiation
consultation with specialists to develop
the proposal that is put forward to us
tonight
i'd like to also congratulate you
councillor watson in your
input for the hard negotiation with
fusion which resulted in the letter that
you read to us tonight
which as you say is a first for fusion
and i think for a small little council
like rockford that is one heck of an
achievement
but let's not forget there is we are
talking about our future here
and the future involves a brand new
purpose-built facility which will serve
all sectors of the community
it's something to look forward to a
little bit of pain to go through first
but that's nothing compared to what
society has been through
i look forward to this project
developing thank you
thank you very much indeed uh councillor
smith and uh
thank you for your your warmer words
there
and um yes i i
agree with everything that you've said
um
i am going to open it up to a visiting
member
councillor danielle belton councillor
belton
thank you i wasn't sure if i was allowed
to ask a question but i thought i'd put
my hand up
and all i wanted to ask is just
following on from some points councillor
made um about the fact that they're
going to be limited facility available
for some of the larger groups that use
the meal on only a couple of
occasions per year for example is there
any possibility of the meal being used
on an
ad hoc basis with fusion running it it's
just something that
come to my mind as councillor was
talking i didn't know if it was
something that that might be possible to
overcome a problem okay thank you
councillor belton
um i've er there's probably a bit of a
parallel with an earlier question from
councillor roe but uh councillor uh
sorry uh mr howard white if you'd be
kind enough to
uh provide an answer there
thank you chairman um thank you
councillor belton um so
in terms of um let's understand the
question sort of uh
one-off bookings i think it's how i
understand that you were referring to
um operationally that wouldn't be
possible um once the sites are
mothballed
um it will be um
operationally and technically uh not
possible to bring it back for those
short one-off
events uh the costs involved in that
getting the site back up and running
we'll be looking at a new financial
model bringing back staff um
a different financial model um which
were impossible unfortunately
no problem thanks for terrifying uh
thank you mr holden
i realized i may have heard a little bit
so in fairness to any other visiting
members i ought to just
uh give them an opportunity um
i know uh councillor wilkinson was good
enough to put his questions on notice
but uh
um if there are any very quick questions
from any other uh
visiting members
no okay all right i can't i can't see
any
um certainly uh alluding to what
councillor smith
uh said um the decision in
august uh just a few months ago
committed us to keep tight control and
look at this very critically before the
end of the year
here we are in early december and we are
looking at it we are looking at
performance
uh we are looking at projections um
because this is an extremely important
decision for us and not one that we
take lightly so uh
i think you know congratulations to our
officer team
uh and certainly congratulations to our
portfolio holder who i know has been on
the case
uh to ensure that we are actually
leading the charge in terms of
maintaining a leisure provision it would
be the easiest decision in the world
to just close these facilities put
fencing up around them and wouldn't they
look awful
and what we're doing is trying to
responsibly
uh temper our investment but at the same
time recognize
the needs of our community so uh my
personal thanks to
uh officers and to council of web for um
you know your
your scrutiny and the conversations that
we've had uh
to make sure that we satisfy ourselves
in preparation of this report
members i see no more hands and i don't
think i'm missing any any
hands on screen um which really takes us
to
the four recommendations um
now i will read out the four
recommendations um
and they are the following consultation
with the portfolio holder for community
and the portfolio holder for finance the
preferred
option set out in paragraph six of this
report
will leisure service provision from the
first of april 2021 be approved
moving on to the second that is
additional budget of one 123
732 over the lifetime
of the contract extension be approved to
enable the preferred
option to be implemented subject to
agreement
by fusion lifestyle fusion to the
proposed
letter of variation to the current
contract
and moving on to three to agree to fund
the additional cost by a leisure
contract smoothing
reserve to be created by moving monies
currently held within the business rates
smoothing reserve which currently has a
balance
of circa 1.3 million pounds
and moving on to four that authority be
delegated to the assistant director
assets and commercial in consultation
with the portfolio holder for community
to enter into a contract variation with
fusion
to implement the preferred option
members i ask you as to whether or not
you're happy to vote on all these
recommendations together
unless you click on your blue
raised hand i will assume that you are
happy to vote on all recommendations
together
and i see again no hand so i take it
that we will vote on
all together and can you also indicate
please
as to whether or not you would like a
recorded boat to be taken
again if you wish one please click on
your
blue hand icon
and again no one is requesting a
recorded vote so members
voting will be done by an electronic
show of hands all those
in favor of the recommendations please
click
on the raised hand icon and
if you are for any reason unable to use
your blue hand
uh please make me aware so that
i can manually count your uh your votes
right just uh bear with me right i think
that's
absolutely everyone i think i'm right
inside that anti-sonia
and thank you yes chairman it's um it's
everyone
and that is unanimously supported
all four recommendations if i'm reading
that correctly sonja
members if you would like to lower your
your blue hand please
right um we move on
to item nine
which is the business essex business
adaptation
fund evash ebath and that is on the
supplementary
agenda and that is to consider the
report of the assistant director place
and environment
seeking approval for the council to
enter into a grant agreement
with essex county council to receive
monies from
physics county council from which to
administer the essex
business adaptation fund in the form of
a grant
payments to local businesses in rochford
district
and i believe its council award
is going to introduce that report
thank you very much chairman uh i'll
only give a brief
overview of what this actually means
due to local and national restrictions
many public-facing
businesses are legally required to make
adaptations to their premises to make
them clove insecure
these adaptations come at a cost that
can be difficult
for businesses to bear in light of
reduced trade
and revenue stemming from the same
restrictions
essex county council has received
funding to the value
of 2.2 million from government to
support
the county's covet 19 response
and has identified from those monies
this grant screen of which 88
000 has been allocated to rochford
the primary purpose of the ebaf
is to fund adaptations businesses
may need to make in response to
continuing coven 19 restrictions
grants of either 500 1000
or 1500 pounds will be available based
on specific eligible items
no business can be awarded more than
fifteen hundred
from the ebf i can give you a brief
summary of the eligibility criteria
which are
businesses must have premises in
rochford district
businesses must be micro small or medium
size
based on the definitions as set out
in the companies act 2006
businesses must self-certify that they
were open
and trading to visiting members of the
public on the 4th of november
2020 businesses must
self-certify that they have fixed
property related
costs businesses receiving a grant
must declare that receipt of the grant
will not cause them to exceed their
legal allowance
under state aid regulations
businesses will not be eligible for a
grant
if they were in administration insolvent
or subject to a striking off notice
at any time between local restrictions
being introduced
and the time of their application being
assessed in their applications
businesses will need to declare what
items
of an adaptation they are claiming for
these include promotional material
advertising
the business is open relevant training
for staff related to covid changes
physical adjustments to premises to make
covid19 secure
creating an online presence to maintain
business continuity
and costs associated with diversifying
operations
well that's including private vehicle
costs for delivery services
access improvements configuration of the
premises
interior and exterior furniture
assuming an average grant of a thousand
pounds
it is likely that around 88 businesses
will be eligible for the ebaf it is
likely
that a fixed application window will
need to be advertised
at launch however given the potential
for demand
to outstrip supply the scheme will need
to operate
on a first come first serve basis
finally items of adaptation
have been classified as having a
notional value
of either 500 1000 or 1500 pounds
whilst the initial assessment will rely
on self-certification essex county
council
has committed to post assurance
quality checks which means taking
necessary action
against any businesses found to have
claimed for items
they have not then implemented i believe
that
this report is full i've just given an
overview of the various items within it
it can be read and looked at and i hope
that members have had an opportunity
to have a look through it and understand
what this is about
i'm happy to take any questions and i
think i've got daniel here
who again is assisting with
this particular grant thank you members
uh council award thank you very much
indeed for your very comprehensive
introduction to uh the report um
members are there any questions and if
so it may be that uh
mr daniel goodman will also be able to
assist members any questions any blue
hands going to appear
think councillor ward you've got off
lightly but obviously your
comprehensive introduction was uh was
good enough to
to deal with any potential questions so
with that i will go to the
recommendations if i may please members
and i will read out the two set out in
paragraphs 1.1
and 1.2 of the report um
one is that the council enters into a
grant agreement with essex county
council
ecc to receive monies from ecc
from which to administer the essex
business adaptations fund
ebaf in the form of grant payments to
local businesses in watchful district
and recommendation two is that the
assistant director for place
and environment finalizes the grant
agreement with
dcc in consultation with the portfolio
holder
or enterprise members are you happy to
vote on those two recommendations
together
i would assume that you're in agreement
unless you click on your
icon your blue hand icon
and again i can't see anyone and
likewise
if you would like a recorded votes can
you also click on your blue hand icon
and i can't see anyone indicating they
wish a recorded vote
so we will move straight to the voting
which will be done
again by an electronic show of hands all
those in favor of the recommendations
please click on your right hand raised
hand icon
and if you've been unable to use know
your looks to me as if everyone
is able to use their blue hand
and again i think that is uh unanimous
sonia if you would just be kind enough
to verify that
yes chairman
okay that recommendation is approved
well those two recommendations are
approved
thank you members that actually
concludes the business for this
meeting um thank you very much indeed
for attending
uh and i declare the meeting closed
at 8 24 p.m
thank you very much indeed members and
have a good question